in pennsylvania a disgusting man
has been nominated by republicans
to potentially be the next governor of
pennsylvania and sadly it is a man named
doug mastriano
who if given the opportunity in 2024 to
steal pennsylvania for the eventual
republican presidential nominee he would
do it
there are two choices in pennsylvania
for governor there's doug mastriano who
is a big lie promulgator
and a guy who would do all the things
trump wanted governors to do for him in
2020 and then you've got democratic
nominee josh shapiro there's not that
much to say about josh shapiro he's a
completely standard
milk toast and i don't say that in a
pejorative just he's just a normal
democrat who wouldn't do anything crazy
he wouldn't try to steal an election and
that's pretty damn good right now
because of what the republican party has
become and now to add on to the
absurdity of doug mastriano
it turns out that doug mastriano once
donned a confederate uniform
confederate uniform while he was in the
military
and as a result more and more
republicans
are endorsing his democratic opponent
josh shapiro business insider reports
seven more republican leaders endorsed
democrat josh shapiro for pennsylvania
governor following news of mastriano
wearing a confederate military uniform
seven more republicans have announced
their endorsement for democrat josh
shapiro one month after nine republicans
called his republican opponent dog
master doug mastriano an extremist a
photo obtained by reuters showed
masteriano posing in a confederate
military uniform
um this is the picture which we're
putting up on the screen for you here
and it is completely vile this is a
picture from 2014
it was taken while then state senator
doug mastriano was part of the faculty
at the us army war college
faculty members were permitted to pose
for the photo while dressed as
historical figures and masteriano chose
a confederate
a confederate uniform
and now is losing the support of at
least a number of republicans so you
know we can talk all day
about the confederate uniform we can say
well you know it's
it is a historical reality
that there were confederate soldiers and
so it's not
necessarily reflective of his
right i'm an idiot i sound like an idiot
when i try to try to say this uh okay
the fact that he is wearing the uniform
alone doesn't mean doug mastriano wishes
we could bring br back uh the enslaving
of black people i'm not saying that but
this is all part of a picture right this
is all part of the bigger picture about
doug mastriano and who he is
uh big lie
conspiracy theorist unhinged number one
secondly
has this campaign advisor who is overtly
as anti-semitic as anyone i've ever
heard of short of you know right i mean
world war ii era german leaders
um
said that
jews don't even have a place in the
republican party even if they're
conservative disgusting right and then
masteriano wears a confederate uniform
so we're building up a picture
that is based on a number of different
pillars and they're all disgusting
rotting pillars covered in pond scum
so it would be great on the one hand if
the more moderate establishment
republicans
jump ship
from these disgusting maga people that's
a good thing because we want the maga
people to lose
on the other hand
if it goes too far
those very
moderate republicans might end up
running as democrats and it could end up
moving the democratic party to the right
which we also don't want we want the
democratic party moving to the left
um and so that's a consideration and
that's a concern as well but it's really
important
really important i mean pennsylvania is
one of the most important states
uh and and you know i'm not saying some
states don't matter
but
you know
wyoming even though liz cheney lost her
primary that's going to be a republican
member of congress either way wyoming is
not going to be the difference maker
over the next two years in the united
states on the other hand look at
pennsylvania pennsylvania is a state
on which control of the senate could
hinge
meaning that the oz versus fetterman
race is extraordinarily important and
pennsylvania is a state on which the
2024 presidential election could hinge
and thus having a governor in
pennsylvania who won't try to steal the
state's electors for the candidate that
didn't win that's an important thing and
so that's why we need josh shapiro to be
the next governor of pennsylvania not
doug mastriano who is just absolutely
and completely vile so
if you're
if you live in pennsylvania of course
you should vote in both of those
elections but no matter where you live
you can phone bank and you can donate in
those two races and they are very very
important races
uh just masteriano is disgusting he's
really the worst of the worst of magat
politics
and uh hopefully we can defeat him in
november
and then he just goes away today is the
david pakman show member town hall the
day has finally come wednesday august
31st unless you're listening to this on
a different day wednesday august 31st is
today at 6 p.m eastern time 3 p.m
pacific we will be doing a member town
hall it will be broadcast for all to see
on youtube twitch and facebook but for
this particular one the participants
will be our members at joinpakman.com
and you can sign up right up until the
start of the town hall at joinpacman.com
so that you can participate today